TRAVELING FROM GREECE TO MOURN
THEIR SONS DAYS AFTER THE
OFFICER WAS TRUCK AND KILLED BY
A DRIVER THAT POLICE SAY WAS
INTOXICATED ON THE L.I.E.
DAVE CARLIN WENT TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN EAST NORTH PORT
TO TALK TO NEIGHBORS WHO KNEW
HIM.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SPOKE TO
CURRENT AND FORMER S.E.A.L.s WHO
WISH TO STAY ANONYMOUS.
AND WHILE MOST OF THE S.E.A.L.s
HAVE SERVED WITH HONOR, WE KNOW
THAT, THEY SAY THE BAD ONES TEND
TO HAVE OUTSIDE -- OUTSIDE
INFLUENCE.
CATHERINE, GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE HEARING THAT ONE OF THE
GUYS USED THE WORD "EVIL," AND
THAT THE SHIFT CAME AFTER THE
BIN LADEN RAID TEN YEARS AGO.
VERY SURPRISINGING.
>> Reporter: WE SPOKE WITH MORE
THAN A DOZEN PEOPLE WHO ARE PART
OF THE S.E.A.L. COMMUNITY OR,
WITH WITH THE S.E.A.L.s AND SAID
THE PROBLEMS PERSIST AND THE
CELEBRITY THAT CAME WITH THE
RAID MADE SOME FEEL UNTOUCHABLE.
DAYS AFTER 9/11, PRESIDENT BUSH
LAUNCHED A MASSIVE GLOBAL
MANHUNT FROM GROUND ZERO.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO KNOCKED THESE
BUILDINGS DOWN WILL HEAR ALL OF
US SOON.
[ CHEERS ]
>> Reporter: A DECADE LATER, THE
SEARCH ENDED AT THIS COMPOUND IN
PAKISTAN WHERE THE QUIET
PROFESSIONALS OF S.E.A.L. TEAM
SIX EXECUTED THE MISSION WERE
AND TLUHRUST INTO THE HEADLINES.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS
CONDUCTED AN OPERATION THAT
KILLED OSAMA BIN LADEN OSAMA BIN
LADEN, THE LEADER OF AL QAEDA.
>> WE LOVE THE JOB.
WE LOVE THE COMMUNITY, BUT IT
HAS TAKEN A WRONG TURN.
>> Reporter: THREE S.E.A.L.s
INCLUDING ONE ON ACTIVE DUTY SAT
DOWN WITH CBS NEWS ON THE
CONDITION WE CHANGE THEIR VOICES
AND HIDE THEIR IDENTITIES.
WHY THE DISGUISE?
>> WE ARE RISKING A LOT TO BE
HERE.
RISKING CAREERS, POSSIBLE
SAFETY.
>> Reporter: THE GROUP TOLD US
THERE ARE BAD S.E.A.L.s WITH
OUTSIDE INFLUENCE ON THE TEAMS.
>> THERE ARE THREE GROUPS IN THE
TEAMS.
THERE'S A SMALL GROUP ON ONE
SIDE THAT IS EVIL.
THEY'RE LAWLESS.
THERE'S A SMALL GROUP ON THE
OTHER SIDE THAT STANDS UP TO
THEM, AND THEN THERE'S A GIANT
GROUP IN THE MIDDLE THAT
COWARDLY STAYS OUT OF IT, AND
THEY WATCH THE EVIL GUYS
RAILROAD THE GOOD GUYS.
>> Reporter: TWO S.E.A.L.s
RECENTLY PLEADED GUILTY IN THE
ST
STRANGULATION OF LOGAN MELBAR IN
AFRICA.
HIS DEATH HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
A HAZING INCIDENT GONE WRONG.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
THIS DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN
SUDDENLY.
THERE WERE 100 STITCHES LEADING
UP TO THAT, LAWAWLESSNESS,
THINKING THEY'RE UNTOUCHABLE.
>> Reporter: THE CONTROVERSIAL
CASE OF EDWARD GALLAGHER ACCUSED
OF KILLING A TEENAGE ISIS
PRISONER IN 2017.
HE WAS PUT ON TRIAL FOR WAR
CRIMES BUT A S.E.A.L. MEDIC WHO
HAD BEEN GRANTED IMMUNITY
CONFESSED TO WHAT HE DESCRIBED
AS A MERCY KILLING.
THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP PUBLICLY
SIDED WITH THE S.E.A.L.
>> WITH EDDIE GALLAGHER, YOU
KNOW THE STORY.
THEY WANT TO TAKE HIS PIN AWAY.
I SAID, NO, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
TAKE IT AWAY.
HE WAS A GREAT FIGHTER.
>> Reporter: IN THE END,
GALLAGHER WAS CONVICTED OF A
LESSER CHARGE OF POSING WITH THE
PRISON'S BODY.
>> I FEEL BETRAYED.
>> Reporter: DRUG ABUSE HAS BEEN
A PROBLEM, TOO.
AROUND 2016, SENIOR S.E.A.L.
COMMANDER JAMIE SANDS READ THE
EAST COAST TEAMS THE RIOT ACT.
>> HOW DO YOU DECIDE WHAT IT'S
OKAY FOR YOU TO DO DRUGS --
>> Reporter: TWO YEARS AFTER
THAT DRESSING DOWN, A HEAVILY
REDACTED NAVY INVESTIGATION
OBTAINED BY CBS NEWS SHOWED SIX
MEMBERS OF S.E.A.L. TEAM TEN
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COCAINE.
YOU HAVE FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF
DEPLOYMENTS WHERE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN TAKING DRUGS.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: AT LEAST ONE
S.E.A.L. ADMITTED HIS COCAINE
USES DURING SNIPER SCHOOL AND ON
DEPLOYMENT.
DRUG USE WENT BEYOND COCAINE TO
METHAMPHETAMINE, ECSTASY, AND
MARIJUANA.
SOME S.E.A.L.s SAID DRUG TESTING
WAS A JOKE.
>> I WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY OF
GUYS ARE NOT DOING IT.
WE'VE GOT TO WORK HARD TO FIND
THE GUYS WHO ARE AND HOW THEY'RE
GETTING IT AROUND.
>> Reporter: ALLEGATIONS OF
DRINKING AND SEXUAL ASSAULT GOT
A S.E.A.L. PLATOON PULLED FROM
IRAQ IN JULY, 2019.
THAT SAME WEEK A MEMO FROM
S.E.A.L. LEADERSHIP READ, "WE
HAVE A PROBLEM."
>> OUR LACK OF ORDER AND
DISCIPLINE COMES FROM WEAK
LEADERSHIP AND NOT ENFORCING THE
STANDARDS.
>> Reporter: THE S.E.A.L.s TOLD
US SPEAKING UP CAN HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
THEY SHOWED US PHOTOS OF A
FELLOW S.E.A.L. WHO THEY SAY WAS
PHYSICALLY BEATEN UP BY SEVERAL
TEAMMATES FOR CALLING OUT BAD
BEHAVIOR.
>> HIS LEADERSHIP TURNED A BLIND
EYE TO IT, DIDN'T ACT ON IT.
AND ESSENTIAY GAVE PERMISSION
TO THE S.E.A.L.s THAT HE ACCUSED
TO DEAL WITH IT ON THEIR TERMS.
>> Reporter: STREET JUSTICE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> YES.
>> FOR THE S.E.A.L.s WATCHING
THIS, THE ONE THING I WOULD WANT
THEM TO THINK ABOUT IS WHERE'S
THE LINE FOR YOU.
AND IF WE CAN'T ALL AGREE THAT
WRONG THINGS ARE WRONG, THEN
IT'S JUST GOING TO KEEP GOING
ON.
>> Reporter: THE ACTING NAVY
SECRETARY AND THE TOP S.E.A.L.
COMMANDER DECLINED ON-CAMERA
INTERVIEWS AND TOLD CBS NEWS IN
A STATEMENT THAT THE S.E.A.L.s
STRIVE TO BE A HIGHLY RELIABLE
TEAM, HUMBLE IN TRIUMPH AND
FULLY ACCOUNTABLE IN FAILURE.
IT DRIVES OUR SENSE OF URGENCY
TO LEARN TO EVOLVE AND COME BACK
STRONGER.
IN PART TWO TOMORROW, WE'LL TELL
YOU ABOUT PROFITEERING.
THE S.E.A.L.s WHO CASHED IN AND
THOSE WHO WERE DISCIPLINED.
ANTHONY?
>> LOOKING FORWARDTOR THAT.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, THANK YOU.
REALLY DISTURBING STORY.
AND THE S.E.A.L.s POINT THE
FINGER AT LEADERSHIP.
>> PRETTY JAW-DROPPING.
I APPRECIATE THEM SPEAKING UP.
I'M GLAD THAT HID THEIR
IDENTITIES BECAUSE I THINK IT
TAKES BRAVERY AND COURAGE TO
TURN ON YOUR OWN AND TO SAY, BUT
WHERE IS THE LINE FOR YOU?
NEVER GOOD WHEN THEY'RE USING
WORDS LAWLESSNESS AND NARCISSISM
AND UNTOUCHABLE.
NOT GOOD.
>> LEADERSHIP IN THE MEMO DID
SAY "WE HAVE A PROBLEM."
THEY RECOGNIZE IT.
>>